welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact it might be hard
to imagine but there's a town within
three hours west of Washington DC where
cell phones radio TV Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
are forbidden Green Bank West Virginia
population 143 is home to the world's
largest steerable radio telescope it's
called the Robert Seberg Green Bank
telescope better known as the gbt the
telescope is taller than the Statue of
Liberty and the dish surface area is big
enough to contain a college football
stadium this is why locals say gbt
stands for great big thing the G BT is a
highly sophisticated device that is
extremely sensitive to even the faintest
radio pulses traveling from distant
galaxies for the same reason it's also
extremely susceptible to any local
interference those restrictions began
back in the 1950s when the FCC created
the National Radio quiet zone it's a
13,000 square mile section of West
Virginia where the Allegheny Mountains
helped create a natural barrier from
radio transmissions the instruments in
the gbt are so sensitive they can detect
a transistor radio on Mars any device in
the quiet zone that generates
electromagnetic radiation even a garage
door opener can distort its readings and
so the people who live in these parts
must by law forgo some of the gadgets
that most of us take for granted but
they don't seem to mind it's hard to
miss the irony that the scientists
living in this area used some of the
world's most advanced instruments but
they can't heat their lunch with a
microwave
you know the Bible
says we all need a quiet zone stay with
us friends we'll learn more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
804 sixty three seventy to ninety seven
now let's join our host pastor Doug
Batchelor and our co-host pastors Jean
Ross welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live if you have a Bible
question the moment has come give us a
call we don't claim to have all the
answers but we have fun looking together
if you want to call lines are open right
now 800 God says is the number that's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and it'll bring your question
into tonight's live program one more
time you ready 800
God says 800 for 63 72 97 my name is
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening listening friends and pastor
Doug as usual let's start with the word
of Prayer
dear father in heaven we thank you once
again that we have this opportunity to
study the Bible together and we ask your
blessing upon those listening and guide
us as we open the scriptures here in the
studio in Jesus name Amen amen well
pastor that you open the program by
talking about a rather interesting fact
I guess it's amazing today thinking that
we are so connected with our phones and
our computers and Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
and you name it to think of a place in
our modern society right in America
where you can't have a cell phone or you
can't be connected to Wi-Fi or you know
you can't just hook up with Bluetooth
anytime you like something rather
different than what we used to and it
seems that folks kind of enjoy it out
there yeah you know it live there when
it the law first was enacted back in the
50s where nobody had wireless phones and
and wireless internet back then and so
they designated this area a quiet zone
and so people who have grown up in the
area or those who have moved in they
knew the rules they say hey we like it
and you know there's even some people
that say that they're physically
sensitive to electromagnetic waves and
they say they're healthier living their
course that's not been backed up by
science yet but some of the people
living there quite sure
of it and but it's interesting that the
people that are there when they're
interviewed they say hey we like it you
know now they do have you know some
electric devices they just have to be
the ones that don't emit a radio
magnetic signal and so you know they
actually can't have a landline phone
because that keeps them the vibrations
in the copper line and and they can have
internet but it has to be hardwired in
it it can't be a wireless internet but
no cell phones and it is funny to think
that here you've got these scientists
living in a very sophisticated area like
that but they can't have a cell phone
matter of fact in the community here in
Green Bank there are actual trucks that
work for the government that drive
around with very sensitive equipment
that listen to anybody that is emitting
forbidden frequencies a few someone's
got a phone and at one time they they
had this big disruption in the satellite
and they try to figure what it was and
it turned out that someone had on an
electric bed for their dog as he gets
colder in the winter the dog came in wet
laid down the bed was shorting out the
telescope detected that well and it
messed up their frequencies and these
guys are driving around in their trucks
and after he's diesel trucks because
diesels have no spark plugs and spark
plugs emit a frequency that interferes
with it's just a very interesting
interesting place but you know it makes
me think we all sort of need a quiet
zone and the Bible even teaches that you
can read for instance in psalm 46 verse
10 be still and know that I am God I
hail from long has it been friends that
are listening this since you've just set
still and tried to listen to the voice
of God's Spirit speaking to you and even
in Isaiah chapter 5 verse 8 there the
prophet says woe unto them to join house
to house that lay field the field till
there is no place that a man might be
placed alone in the midst of the earth
it sounds like a modern subdivision
doesn't it sometimes you need to get out
where you can just be still and listen
to the voice of God speaking to you now
prayer is where we talk to God but
that's not all of prayer part of prayer
is where we're listening to God's
to us through the Holy Spirit and the
Holy Spirit is not just a force it's not
some mystical cloud that communicates
with us it is God the spirit who speaks
to us and it's important to understand
this person of the Godhead and we have a
free offer tonight that will tell you
more about how you can be filled with
the spirit and know who God the Spirit
is we have a book called the Holy Spirit
the need written by pastor Doug and
we'll be happy to send this to anybody
who calls and asked just after the book
on the Holy Spirit is called the Holy
Spirit the need the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven the number
again is 808 three five six seven four
seven and as for the book called the
Holy Spirit the need and if you have a
Bible Christian a phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven okay one more time you ready
804 63 72 97 going to the phone lines
our first caller is Rolando listening
from Western Florida
Rolando welcome to the program thank you
good evening pastor doug and pastor roth
evening how you cool on your visitors
thank you for taking my call and for
doing the work of the Lord it's a
blessing so here's my question we know
that we are to work on building our
characters in this life so that we can
reflect Jesus what about the thief on
the cross and will his character be
perfected on Resurrection Day and if not
will he need to work on his character in
heaven
well can I answer your question with a
question please sure if a person comes
to Jesus and when they accept Jesus and
surrender their lives to him and accept
the the sacrifice that he's made for
their sins uh if they should die are
they saved yeah how much time ever they
had to develop new habits a new
character so
not just asking about the thief on the
cross we're asking about anybody right
you know as soon as we surrender our
lives to the Lord when you have a
born-again experience the Holy Spirit
moves into your heart right then you are
saved based on your faith and belief in
God's substitution in your behalf
now part of the work of a Christian from
that moment on is to strive to be more
and more like Jesus and that's the
character development that you're
talking about but you're not saved based
upon how advanced your degree of
character development you're saved based
upon your fully surrendering and
accepting his sacrifice in your behalf
and then your sanctification continues
to go on where we're saved based on not
being perfect by complete reprogramming
at the moment of conversion because
Isaiah said learn to do good that you
resist evil you learn to do good but
it's being fully surrendered day by day
as you follow the Lord you maintain a
safe relationship you might have plenty
of character development left to go it's
the difference between justification and
sanctification
we're justified when we come to the Lord
just like we are that's the thief on the
cross now I think part of your question
is so if a person like the thief on the
cross that accept it and we have friends
listening may wonder what I'm talking
about there was a man that was crucified
by Jesus and in the final hours of his
life he turned to Christ and Jesus said
you'll be saved you'll be with me in
paradise
well you know you didn't have a lot of
time to learn to be a Christian he
hadn't gone to church he hadn't been
baptized and when he gets to heaven is
he going to be just sort of a reforming
thief that's view and I would say that
his heart he got the new heart right
there on the cross and salvation is
about the new heart and conversion so
really have a lot of learning left in
heaven yeah matter of fact there is
never a time in heaven when you stop
learning does that make sense
absolutely thank you for taking my call
all right hey thank you so much
pastor Roseboro we do it well we've got
a book called the surrender of self and
I think that's the key God is looking
for men and woman who are surrendered to
him so that he can work within them
we'll be able to send this book to
anybody who calls an assets called the
surrender of self the number is 883 five
six seven four seven you can answer the
book called
the surrender of self and if you have a
Bible question we'd love to hear from
you this evening we have some lines that
are still open the number to call is 800
four six three seven two nine seven that
number again is 804 63 72 97 we're gonna
go to Patrick listening also in Florida
Patrick welcome to the program Patrick
you're on the air hi how's it going
doing well how can we help you tonight
yeah I just had a question as far as um
when we get to heaven is there will
there be any procreation happening in
heaven in other words will there be sex
in heaven yes I don't think so
and it's gonna be hard to give you a
chapter and verse on this but there is
that one statement where Jesus said and
pastor Ross might help me look it up
it's in a couple of Gospels in his
dialogue with you
look what honey to verse 30 yeah one you
want to read that real quick yeah Jesus
speaking in the resurrection they shall
neither marry nor given in marriage but
I like the angels of God in heaven now
see in the beginning what God made Adam
and Eve he told them go forth be
fruitful and fill the earth well that
means you know populate the earth
obviously at some point God would say
yep it's pretty well populated and we'll
stop right there you know I understand
that you got some places in the world
where there's like you know ten thousand
people per square mile it's really
densely populated
I don't think Heaven's gonna be that
dense or there'd be no country we were
just talking about that so God is gonna
populate the world the new earth he
creates with the redeemed so we may
still have lots of close relationships
in heaven and people we love but
don't believe there'll be a need for
procreation now some people when they
hear that especially I go around I talk
to young people and I do you know weeks
of prayer at schools and when the young
people here that I see there may not be
sex in heaven they think oh man you know
I don't know if I want to go anymore
there's not sincere they think you know
there it's one of those strong driving
forces and they get God designed it to
be pleasurable and people think will I
be happy and I have to remind them you
are gonna be infinitely happier in
heaven with all the the Bible says what
are the Psalm 16 at his right hand are
pleasures forevermore all kinds of ink
it bliss and wonderful pleasures in
heaven we can't even fathom the colors
you're gonna see in heaven would be
banner better than any earthly desire
here and God says you can't even imagine
what its gonna be like and so don't
anybody think oh man if there's not
marriage in heaven or if there's not sex
in it but I'm not sure it's gonna just
sitting on a cloud play a harp what are
you gonna do I think it's just
misconceptions about heaven but nope I
don't think there's gonna be procreation
that did we lose pet Petric you still
there no okay
yeah so I don't know if that helps but
there's not a lot of Scripture on it but
it doesn't seem there's gonna be
procreation in the resurrect falling the
resurrection okay the verse is Matthew
22 verse 30 volson mark chapter 12 verse
25 and Luke 17 verse 27 three gospel
record okay thank you so much thank you
Mexico Lee's Jamie also listening in
Florida Jamie welcome to the program
yeah I got a question okay I know I know
this I understand and I see very clearly
the saddest truth then I see that the
fourth commandment is the seal of God
now when I read Matthew 5:19 he's
telling me that those are don't keep it
and don't teach you they're going to be
least in the kingdom of heaven I'm not
great which me
they're going to be in the kingdom of
heaven Council and I have heard you say
that millions of people there are some
day keepers will be in heaven so that's
how could that be if they know if you
don't have this little girl in your
forehead because you don't keep this up
all right you're asking a couple of good
questions there but I got to divide them
first of all will there be people in
heaven that maybe didn't keep the Ten
Commandments the way they should
absolutely there will be people in
heaven like King David that had way too
many wives not to mention he did commit
adultery but he repented of that and
Solomon that had too many wives God
winked at their ignorance because they
didn't know there will be people in
heaven that went to church maybe or kept
the wrong day as the Sabbath because
they didn't know the Bible says sin is
knowing to do good and not doing it so
that's one issue but I think you're
misunderstanding Matthew 5:19 where it
says those who break one of the least of
the commandments and teach others to do
so will be called least in the kingdom
it doesn't mean they're there and they
just have all you know they don't have
the gold medal they got the bronze medal
that's not what it's saying it's saying
those in the kingdom of heaven call them
the lowest kind of person they're not in
the kingdom they are being spoken of by
those in the kingdom as the lowest
that's what it's saying it's not saying
they're there it says those in the
kingdom of heaven will call them the
lowest person it's not that they just I
mean God's not gonna take someone to
heaven that is teaching others to break
is law and of course you Jesus is
talking about anyway
yeah she's talking to the religious
ladies in particular here yeah and they
were considered to be great law keepers
by the people but in reality they were
breaking God's commandments and Jesus
goes on to cite some examples of that
and he's really telling them people
might think you great here on this earth
but it's a different story in heaven and
that's kind of the point that's being
emphasized there yeah so yeah I I don't
think people who are deliberately
teaching others to break God's law
knowing they break God's law are gonna
be there I'm sorry you still there Jamie
yeah yeah real quick real quick okay so
people that
have ears to hear what the word is
saying they don't see when they read the
Bible as our students because it's so
clear that something that got kept
themselves in the first week of creation
and he hollered and sanctified and kept
to himself well they're in you know yeah
there are people that I you know we got
to be careful not to judge others there
are people that read things in the Bible
and and they're not sure what it means
and maybe there's religious leaders are
telling me well this is how you
interpret it they're sincere and and
they don't know and God God knows you
know what their level of understanding
is but and it's not just with this one
commandment it's with several other
Commandments people they're doing their
best to live up to what they understand
but there's a lot of things they don't
understand we've got a book that talks
about the the law in particular that we
can send Jamie a copy if we have a book
called why God said remember that talks
about the fourth commandment and I'll be
able to send this to anybody who calls
and asks the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven can ask for the book called why
God said remember then I'm again is 808
three five six seven four seven and the
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
again that's 804 63 72 97 and actually
is fill listening from New York Phil
welcome to the program
loud and clear yes could you tell me if
you know what is meant by the term I
think it's pronounced tetra graviton and
have any connection with the letters yhw
H yes they're one in the same
that is a long word I think it's I think
that's a Latin isn't it that is talking
about the holy name of God and the Jews
when they would come to the name Yahweh
no one knows exactly how to pronounce
that some will argue that it's Jehovah
others Yahweh they would leave out the
vowels
and it left people and if they felt you
know this is the sacred name of God and
so it was considered too sacred day even
right and so sometimes you'll just see
the word Lord and your King James Bible
its capital lor D and that's usually
where you would see the word Yahweh
those four sacred letters okay thank you
so very much so there is a connection
between the two things I mentioned yes I
think that you're talking about the
official word for now I've got a book I
can send you where I talk about that and
it's called the name of God will send
you a free copy if you like you know
what I appreciate you already answered
my question you guys have a great show
you know precisely what you're talking
about but you use plain language and I
think you're hitting the nail right on
the head and I really appreciate it
well that's very kind thank you so much
Phil we appreciate it okay good thanks
to kool Phil if you have a Bible
question the phone line here the studio
again is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 for 63
72 97 we've got Susan oh he's listening
in Utah Susan off to the program doing
well how can we help you tonight I had a
strange thing happened to me and I I've
researched it trying to find it to see
if it's true
years ago I had a bunch of traffic
tickets and so I went down so I was just
waiting to go to the church on Sunday
and Saturday night I had gotten an
adverse out of the Bible and I taped it
to my bunk
and for some reason the next day when I
went to church I was in a really really
bad mood I don't know why and it was not
the regular one and she said she had a
lesson that he had all planned out but
God put it on her heart the next words
out of her mouth was that verse now
what's a verse what is the verse I can't
remember it exactly it was David
God what is what is it that you need me
to do for you or something along those
lines because it was years ago I can't
remember but well there's I'm sorry go
ahead
listening and everything she was talking
about was my life I mean it was me and
at the end of the service everybody was
going up to her and as soon as I went up
to her she said you're the one God
talking to you aren't you and I
immediately started crying said yes I
think so and she told me something that
is very strange she said that I had the
crown of Barnabas and at the time I had
no clue Barnabas was and then she had
somebody read off Isaiah 41:10 to me and
ever since then I mean I've looked I've
read about who Barnabas is and I mean I
I could be like I mean well I wouldn't
let me try and dive in here because we
got to kind of pull this into a question
the first of all the word crown in the
Bible is stefanos and I don't know that
there's any where the Bible it talks
about the crown of Barnabas the name
Barnabas means son of consolation
whatever you see bar in the Bible it
means son of and I don't know what this
sister may have been sharing with you I
mean who knows what the Lord put on her
heart at that moment when she shared
that with you
she might mean when she said Barnabas
was always a very consoling person he
took Paul under his wing he was very
kind person in the Bible to others I
don't know if she was saying that you've
got this aura of Barnabas character
about you and when the the place where
in the Bible where it says Lord what
will you have me do there's a couple
places where individuals said that to
the Lord
trying to think where David said it
though but yeah you know
it's important that all of us kind of
humble ourselves before the Lord and say
you know Lord what do you want me to do
I'm Yours so I don't know if that's
helping to answer your question Susan
that you had like the crown thing I mean
do the same I don't all right well there
is a place in the Bible where it talks
about the redeemed do have crowns in
Revelation and the Bible you know Paul
says don't let anyone take your crown
and we're all gonna be rewarded in the
kingdom so that could be what they were
talking about yeah the verse you
referring today's Revelation chapter 3
verse 11 behold I am coming quickly hold
fast what you have that no one take your
crown yep there's out of life crown of
victory and we appreciate your call
Susan we're gonna try and squeeze in one
more before our halftime break
we have Jim listening from Las Vegas Jim
walk to the program I good evening
doing well how can we help tonight okay
I have a question of brother in Christ
and I were speaking and he brought up a
hypothetical situation he said what if a
person had robbed the bank or even
committed murder and did not tell anyone
and then all of a sudden he accepts
Christ as his personal Savior becomes a
Christian and he said do you think that
person still goes to heaven and I said
well I said there is no condemnation for
those who believe in Christ that's what
the Bible development and I'm like I'm
not sure I said that's a good question
you know so that's like they decided to
call in and ask that question all right
well we appreciate that first of all
there's no question that there are
people that were robbers and even
murders that repented of their sin David
committed murder
Moses committed murder Paul committed
murder
he was an accessory anyway
that we're all forgiven so the question
might be more precisely can they be
forgiven without confessing and of
course you've got to confess your sin to
God and I would say that you know if a
person comes to the Lord if you're a
thief and you stolen something and you
say well thank you Jesus and you still
got your neighbor's chainsaw on your
garage you got to take it back
you can't just repent and say Lord I'm
sorry and not go tell your neighbour and
take back the chainsaw some things you
cannot reverse you kill someone you
can't bring them back you might need to
come clean with what your crime is and
so you know sometimes there's
consequences for those things but hope
that helps a little bit Jim that's a
quick answer but yeah God is there's
gonna be murders in heaven and this can
be thieves in heaven and there's gonna
be adulterers and adulteresses in heaven
and all kinds of things that God
forgives but anyway hey we appreciate
your call we do have some lines open
friends call for the next half 800 for
six three seven two nine seven for your
Bible questions we're gonna catch our
breath and we'll be back in just a
moment
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz and the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelist circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live we still have a few phone
lines open if you have a Bible related
question call us at one eight hundred
seven eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven now let's join pastors
doug batchelor and john ross for more
Bible answers live
welcome back and those who joined us
along the way this is Bible answers live
and we have some lines open if you have
a Bible question good chance your
question will be part of tonight's
broadcast that number once again 800 for
six three seven two nine seven that's
800 God says with your questions my name
is Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
and we gonna go to an ice cola
we've got Kimberly listening from
Virginia Kimberly welcome to the program
hi how are you doing well thank you
I wanted to know there's a scripture and
I can't remember exactly where it is but
I think I know Paul is either Asian or
maybe Romans I'm not sure where it says
your loved ones that's gone you know
ahead before you are you know cheering
you on or rooting you on and my question
is what does the deceased are they able
to see or what do they see are they even
able to see what's going on on the earth
alright well first of all I think
there's a couple verses you could be
referring to one may be Hebrews 11 where
it says R 12 where we're surrounded by
so great a cloud of witnesses yes yes
that's 12 verse 1 let me read the verse
just forget the context therefore we
also since we are surrounded by such a
great cloud of witnesses let us lay
aside every weight and the sin that so
easily ensnares us and let us run with
endurance the race that he set before us
yeah Paul makes that statement at the
end of chapter 11 of course where he
highlights chapter 11 is called the Hall
of faith that highlights all the great
men and women of faith in Bible history
and so he's just saying that we have the
testimony of all these great witnesses
that surround us it doesn't mean I mean
you think about it it doesn't mean Moses
in Abraham and all those are looking
down on everybody on earth
well most people I mean you do have
Elijah went to heaven in a fiery chariot
and Moses was resurrected it tells us
that Jude and and you have Enoch that
walk with God and God took him
but for the foremost people that die it
says the living no they'll die and this
is ecclesiastes 9:9 but the dead know
not anything and so the dead are
sleeping a peaceful dreamless sleep
until the resurrection now if you are a
believer and you die it doesn't seem
like any time has gone by because for
you your next conscious thought is the
resurrection and for you to be absent
from the body next thing you know is the
presence of the Lord
it'll seem like the Bible calls it a
moment the twinkling of an eye but Jesus
is really clear the resurrection is at
the end of time he says that three times
in John chapter 6 the last day I will
raise them up the last day the great
Judgment days in the future and so the
judgment and the resurrection haven't
happened yet for us living on earth and
so the dead are not up in heaven spying
on us which is probably a comforting
thing because just think about it for a
minute if you had a good Christian
mother and she died and and she's up in
heaven she's looking at all the trials
and tribulations you go through and
write and see they're not gonna be very
happy in heaven seeing all that so
they're resting and they will be that's
why they say our IP on the graves rest
in peace they're resting until the
resurrection and so that verse in
Hebrews 12 is just saying we've got this
biblical record of witnesses that should
encourage us that doesn't mean we're
being spied on beautifully perfect and
that's what I thought but I wasn't sure
and I just wanted to get clarity on that
so you said it queasy at 9 weeks worth
anything well you know we got a study
guide yeah that actually got that first
and a lot of other verses these sn95 and
others it's called are the dead really
dead and we'll be able to send this to
you Kimberly or anybody wanting to learn
more about the subject or you're left to
do just give us a call on our resource
phone line which is 808 three five six
seven four seven and you can ask for the
study guide called are the dead really
dead I'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks you can also
go to a web site that amazing facts
called death truth calm just death truth
calm you can read the scriptures they're
related to the subject you can even
watch some video dealing with the
subject of what happens when a person
dies no pathos just before we go to the
next chart you reminded me of something
I just totally forgot about as of this
broadcast this weekend a movie open in
the theater tonight
I don't ever encourage people to go to
the theaters and I'm not starting now
but just wanted to tell people that
there's a new film out called hacksaw
Ridge by Mel Gibson
that is about a it's actually about a
seventh-day Adventist war hero named
Desmond das it's a true story and I I
knew the man and his his wife would come
to our church her family was in our
church up in Northern California and
just say it's an incredible story we
have the book amazing facts and remnant
publications has been allowed permission
to print the authorized biography of
this guy man's life and it is so
inspiring how just he stood for his
convictions he wouldn't carry a gun into
battle and yet he got the Congressional
Medal of Honor for heroism if you want
to know more about how you can get a
copy of that book to read it or to share
with your friends this is a great time
to share the gospel in the back of the
book it talks about the faith of Desmond
dass I wrote a little section in there
then go to the amazing facts website
you'll see the ad there for the hero of
hacks are rich it's called the hero of
hacksaw Ridge we actually got permission
from the movie theater to put out this
book and I think 1 million of them have
been printed in preparation for this so
get them and send them out again just go
to the amazing facts website just
amazing facts dot o RG and if you don't
see the banner right at the top just
type in the search bar hack so reg and
it'll take you straight to the resource
click on that and I think we have a
limited number pass that either we're
actually giving away for people who
actually go to the way we are giving
water away for free I don't know how
long it's gonna last so if anybody would
like to get one and get it for free you
probably need to go to the website right
away
our next caller is Pedro listening from
San Antonio Texas
spitter often to the program hi you're
there yes my question is from Revelation
chapter 4 verse 4 it talks about 24
elders who are these twenty-four elders
and where do they come from I've got an
unwritten agreement with pastor Ross
that I get 65 books in the Bible and he
gets one and so I let him view the
revelation questions well there just
happens in Revelation happens to be one
of my favorite books and I do have an
opportunity to teach our evangelism
group the book the 24 elders that you
read about in Revelation chapter and
pass that I do jump in now just share
what my understanding is there's two
principal interpretations as to who they
are the one being that they are the
representatives of the unfallen world
it's the same group that you read about
in the book of Job where it talks about
the sons of God meeting and Satan came
representing the earth and God said
where did you come from this is walking
up and down on the earth and that's the
one idea as to who they are and I think
that is the accurate one there is
another that suggests that at the time
of Christ's resurrection when the graves
open and many of those who slept in the
grave arose that they went with Jesus to
heaven when he ascended and the verse
that says he led captivity captive and
gave gifts unto men a reference to those
as firstfruits that rose from the dead
with Christ and ascended to heaven that
they could be the 24 elders but I think
if you line up all of the scriptures it
seems to make more sense that these 24
elders would be the representatives of
unfallen worlds and you can also read in
the Old Testament about how it says the
Lord reigns before his elders gloriously
so we have that references in the Old
Testament does that help a little Pedro
helps very much all right he thank you
very much thank you do we I was just
thinking we have that book that does
talk about that who are the sons of God
oh that's right and we do we got a book
we can send you I don't know if you're
still listening call the resource number
and ask for the book who are the sons of
God the number to call is 800 835
six seven four seven you can ask for the
sharing book called who are the sons of
God that number again is 808 three five
six seven four seven and if you have a
Bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four six
372 97 Kaneda is our next caller
listening from Alabama
Juanita welcome to the program hello how
are you doing doing well I'm just
curious did we say your name right miss
Quinn in it hey thank you so much for
your call your question tonight okay
question is I was where can I find
scripture about how to raise your
children the Lord okay well there's
actually quite a few one of the most
important is well it Bible tells us
Abraham commanded his household after
him then you go to Deuteronomy and after
Moses reads the Ten Commandments for the
second time he says in Deuteronomy 6 and
these words that I command you this day
will be in your heart and he goes on to
say you shall teach them diligently to
your children when you lay down and when
you rise up when you walk by the way
they're to be on the doorposts of your
house and so one thing is have morning
and evening worship set down the
principles of what it means to be a
Christian for your children and it says
when you walk by the way your children
need to see their parents walking the
walk so it's one thing if you say we're
gonna have morning worship and evening
worship we're gonna read a verse here
and read a verse there and they even
memorize the Bible but if we're not
living it they need to see when you're
walking by the way they need to see it
on the doorpost of your house meaning
it's observed in the home and Paul talks
about training your children and the
admonition of the Lord there's quite a
few verses that talk about the
importance of training children yeah you
get up a gaggle of kids well I think
absolutely what you saying pastor day
it's not only what you say but it's who
you are and what you do and you've
probably heard it said that most of what
kids learn from their parents they learn
by
observation not necessarily by
instruction so the way we respond to
each other is going to be an object
lesson for the kids so yes share within
the scripture make sure you make that a
priority morning worship evening worship
and then of course
Olivia Christian belief and yeah
pray for your kids that they will also
follow the Lord I heard one person say
that Christianity with children is more
caught than taught mm-hmm
they catch it by watching hey Thank You
Quinn Etta and appreciate your question
I'm trying to think well we've got a
books on that we got our video series
that we did you did a series on
Christian parenting
yeah raising kids for heaven that's I
don't think we can give that away for
free may not be at her site there's so
many of our things people buy them and
put them on YouTube so yeah you know I
haven't seen it there but just go to the
amazing facts websites the amazing facts
dot o-r-g annex collie is Arlene
listening from Brooklyn New York
Arlene welcome to the program hi good
evening
you mean I must unless say I enjoy the
program week after week my question is
more of a moral question rather than
directly Bible it's based on biblical
living Christian living
I've been going to various places from
time to time to do shopping where the
bakery where their hardware store
whatever but I have been finding if I go
to began to place and I bought something
and then the next thing I know when I
get better to my car or at home I found
that I got more than what I bought and
I'm perplexed and it's happening I
stopped going to one place I go
someplace else the same thing happened I
don't know the people but I'm getting
more than what I've paid for so
yesterday it happened again I went to
the hardware store and the young lady
couldn't find the price for the thing
and whatever and then she said you know
what just take it forget it and and I'm
wondering yesterday it started to
concern me will is this a blessing is
this God just because I'm going through
a hard season is this God encouraging me
is this God showing me favor or should I
return this thing when
discover well I have you know if I buy
one bread I get an extra bread or
something like that and it's not like
something's not an oversight it's
purposefully done and it's happening
from place to place so what do you think
as a Christian what should i what do you
think what we do advise yeah well that's
a good question I think that the first
thing is if if you're at the checkout
stand and they knowingly say you know
we're gonna give you a better price or
we're gonna just let you have this ID
count that as a blessing it's perfectly
legal they're just wanting to bless you
and I'd say thank you and be grateful if
you walk out of a store and you bought
one hammer and the receipt says one
hammer you got two hammers in your bag
you might want to come back to the store
and say I don't know how I ended up with
two hammers in my bag now the reason I
say that is you remember when Joseph's
brothers when they left Joseph put their
money back in their bags they were
honest and they went back to the steward
and said you know we brought back the
money because we ended up with extra
money and grain in our bags and and the
steward said the Lord's blessed you keep
it the Lord put money in your bag and so
as long as they were upfront with it it
was a blessing from God but they didn't
feel comfortable taking something where
it could have been taking advantage of
somebody so once or twice I walked out
of the store and I saw they gave me too
much change or you look in your bag and
say oh I thought I'd only paid for one
of these and they put two in the bag
well you know your conscience says you
need to go back and make it right and
you know sometimes it's a great witness
when people know you've gotten out of
the store with extra money and your
conscience goes back and you say look
I'm a Christian and I just realize you
gave me two minutes change and I can't
take this and it makes a statement it's
an opportunity to witness so that's a
great question if they give it to you at
the checkout stand and they're aware
then it's a blessing but if you get home
and you think it was a mistake then you
want to write that appreciate your
question Arlene thank you very much for
calling a nice Holy's George listening
from Montana George welcome to the
program hi good evening evening my
question that my question has to do with
the commandments thou shalt not kill
along that line people think that I've
talked to who are Christians think that
that is basically you're not supposed to
kill anything are we supposed to kill in
the name of the Lord
well now killing the the commandment
technically does not say thou shalt not
kill I know I know if you read it in the
Bible you're gonna find the King James
translation says that but if you look
for instance in Luke 18 where Jesus says
you know the commandments do not commit
adultery do not murder do not steal the
word murder is really what you find in
the Hebrew where it says thou shalt not
kill it's talking about the wrongful
taking of human life right when you kill
a you swat a mosquito you're killing
technically right if you going down the
road and you hit a bunny you kill it I
mean and you're not gonna be called a
murderer so and even if a person dies
accidentally in the Bible you were
forgiven if there was an accidental
murder you could flee to the City of
Refuge and be forgiven and in our
culture they call it manslaughter and
there's a variety of different statutes
on on how they deal with that it's
premeditated taking of innocent life if
you're if someone dies in self-defense
of your family if you've got an intruder
in your home and they're killed in the
process
you're never prosecuted as a murder so
when God sent his army out to fight in
defense of the country obviously God is
commanding them to kill but they're not
murdering we never call soldiers
murderers when they're defending the the
national interests right so the word
technically is murder otherwise every
time you pull a weed in your garden
you're breaking the commandment what's
right yeah and so look in the New
Testament where Jesus says it you'll see
that in in Luke Mark Matthew Jesus uses
the word murder when he recites that
commandment because it is a technically
it is a different word okay Luke mark
and
yeah look I ran a tag on but mark 10 19
Jesus said do not murder Luke 18 20 he
says do not murder and in there are
several references here Matthew 19 18
has it there hey thank you very much we
appreciate your question George and we
do have a book on the law we'll send you
a free copy and it's called written in
stone a free study guide the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask the
study guide called written in stone and
we'll be happy to send us to you George
or anybody who calls and asks our next
call is Henry listening from Bronx New
York
Henry welcome to the program all the
animals in the garden yeah now when we
say the word dinosaurs were always
thinking of the very large reptiles or
the Raza yeah but I think that there
were all kinds of animals that were in
the garden in the world before the flood
that have been rendered extinct since
then even in the last 300 years
there are thousands I think it's
thousands of species of animals that
have gone extinct and so there were a
lot of very large not only reptiles but
we have fossils of very large mammals
that lived in antiquity a Bible talks
about nimrod the mighty hunter and he
wasn't called a mighty hunter because he
was shooting rabbits i've been talking
about rabbits a lot tonight poor things
but you could call the mighty hunter
when you're bringing down mighty beasts
and it could have been it he was
fighting with some of these lizards and
Bible and history all over the world
talks about dragons and and so I think
there were a very large reptiles that
lived contemporaneously with man and God
told Noah take two of everything on the
flood on the ark and he didn't need to
take great big dinosaurs he could have
taken baby ones or eggs even and so he
was ordered to preserve life of all the
creatures but following the flood
wickedness increased again and a lot of
animals I think were exterminated some
maybe didn't survive
and so those fossils that we see of
these great reptiles that may have lived
hundreds of years
you know crocodiles can live over a
hundred years now they get pretty big
and so yeah I believe that there were
great dinosaurs and they were also
enormous mammals
I saw a fossil of a 13 foot tall beaver
and so it kind of they had they had all
kinds of enormous animals and we've
heard about the Megalodon these sharks
they could swallow a Volkswagen anyway
so that's a long answer was over a
million years ago well I respectfully
disagree with the dates that are given
by a lot of paleontologists I think that
those dates are they're using bad
science to come to those dates they just
discovered a Tyrannosaurus Rex I guess
had been about six years ago they saw
through a thigh bone and they found soft
tissue and it just sent the
paleontologists on their head because
they said there's no way soft tissue and
blood cells could survive in the morrow
of a bone for 60 million years so I
think they're beginning to reconsider
their dating methods maybe very flawed
hey thank you I appreciate your call
Henry now wondering we we got a magazine
at amazing facts about dinosaurs we do
yes we call it a comic book cause it's
Illustrated but it's really actually
very informative probably have to go to
the amazing facts website or just
amazing facts or gene you can I think
it's in our resource area and you can
type in there dinosaurs and we'll have
some resources including that book our
next call is Carole listening from San
Francisco
hi Carole welcome to the program thank
you I'm struggling to believe in
believing in God my brother says that I
feel like I'm more moral than God
because I told him I'm struggling with a
god that would torture sinners who
didn't make it for ever and ever and
ever and I don't know what the purpose
of that would be Carole I'm so glad you
called oh goodness
for you the bible does not teach that
and you know one of the things that kept
me away from god i was an atheist
growing up and one of the things that
kept me from God is I went to a couple
of Christian schools where I was told if
you're real good you go to heaven and if
you're bad even if you you know you die
fifteen years old you're gonna get
tortured in fire for billions of years
times billions of years beyond eternity
and I thought wow God is a sadist
the bible does say there is punishment
for the wicked and there is the wicked
are cast into the lake of fire and it
says they are consumed the bible says
they are devoured you can read in
Malachi chapter 4 the day is coming when
all the proud and all that do wickedly
will be stubble it will burn them up it
will leave them neither root nor branch
jesus said we have two choices whoever
believes in Him will have a heavy
everlasting life and they will not
perish and so it's you either perish or
everlasting life Adam and Eve were told
you eat from the forbidden tree and
you'll die in Ezekiel it says you either
live or die
and so the wicked are punished they are
cast on the lake of fire and people have
misunderstood a few verses but there's a
whole lot more verses in the Bible that
make it clear that the wicked do not
burn forever that everyone is punished
according to what they deserve now
follow me Carol the Bible says the
penalty for sin is death Jesus died on
the cross to take our penalty if the
penalty for sin is burning forever in
hell then he didn't take our penalty
because he just was in the grave for
three days are you with me so this is a
teaching that came out of the the
medieval church began to mingle Greek
mythology with Christianity to scare
people into the church but this is not
what the Bible taught it's not what the
Apostles believed I know there's some
dear Christians out there that believe
that and I just I was so relieved to
read for myself what the Bible really
said and we will send you a study guide
that has all the biblical references on
this or anyone that wants to better
understand the love of God regarding the
punishment of the wicked the study guide
is called is the
Evelynn charger hell we'll be happy to
send that to anybody who calls and asks
again is called is the devil in charge
of hell the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and asked that study guide
also Carolee you can go to a website
called hell truth comm and you can study
this subject further the website is just
simply hell truths calm or call our
resource phone number and ask for the
study guide called is the devil in
charge of hell thank you so much thank
you Carolyn you're gonna find God as a
God you can love and that's what really
changed everything for me and listening
friends I don't think we've got time to
do another question justice I see a few
calls standing by and if we did not get
to your question tonight we apologize we
hope you'll give us another chance I
want to reiterate an announcement we
made a little earlier there is a
phenomenal story that is hitting the
feeders about an incredible man by the
name of Desmond dass now the name of the
movies hacks are rich and again I
understand it's very violent movie I've
not been to see it we don't encourage
people to go to theaters and as a
practice I don't go to the movie theater
because most of it probably not good for
your soul but the story is a true story
and if you'd like to read the biography
of this myth Desmond and Florence dogs
were actually supporters of amazing
facts I'd love to throw that in he was
an incredible a World War two hero and
if you go to the amazing facts website
you look at our banners that rotate
through there you'll see one about the
hero of Hacksaw Ridge you need to read
that biography we're for a short time
we're giving away copies of the book and
so you want to go there and it's you buy
it it doesn't cost that much either and
it'll change your life
by a bunch and share them with your
friends friends yeah god bless you
remember the reason we do this is
because jesus is the truth that is going
to set you free well talk together again
next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world
beyond the Great Wall the printing and
translation of our books and video
materials are in constant motion
southeast Ohio faith oxygen tisha
Juliana China - the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come
you know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but lights got in the
way
next thing I know we're month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today by calling